foreign
[Music]
thank you for the introduction
so biological systems are intricately
spatially organized uh right now we have
tools such as bulk and single cell
sequencing
these can show us parts of a biological
system but they can't show us the entire
picture
they can give us information on a tissue
level as to what is going on at the
tissue level but they can't show us how
cells are spatially organized
and so wait here at vizgen we want to
move towards providing spatial genomics
with true single cell resolution
we feel that this offers a higher level
of insight in order to look at very
tough complex biological systems
and so in order for us to do that here
at vizgen we have developed the mersco
platform this is a comprehensive
platform that allows users to run
hundreds to thousands of genes in a
single run we can detect transcripts
from all of those genes it's highly
sensitive and accurate
we boast a large Imaging area of one
square centimeter at a resolution of 100
nanometers and so what this gives you
the ability to do is look at an entire
tissue section look at different regions
and then zoom into specific areas and
look at how cells are interacting what
those cells are doing and how they're
functioning
there's no need for sequencing with our
system as it is based on our proprietary
Murphy technology which I'll get into in
a second
and in addition to being being a
comprehensive system we've also built in
a user-friendly aspect
so our system comes with Control
software and visualization software that
allows users to look at their data and
Visually identify different different uh
items within that data different data
sets all of this with an intuitive
system
in addition to that we offer a web-based
gene panel application this allows users
to build Gene panels for their specific
research build those custom panels
within their application areas and we
see a wide range of application areas
being used or being studied with our
system and so we're very excited to to
offer these these features
and so I mentioned our system is based
on merfish that stands for Multiplex air
robust fluorescent in situ hybridization
this is a proprietary technology it is
uh unique to visjet
merfish is built on SM fish SM fish
allows direct quantification of RNA
targets within tissue
we combine that with our proprietary
barcoding system that allows us to build
these Gene panels to Target more than
500 team targets and detect all of those
transcripts within a single experiment
we combine SM fish with our proprietary
barcoding system
what this gets us is a highly
multiplexed RNA detection system called
murphish that enables single cell
analysis
the Aero robustness of merfish allows
for that high accuracy and consistency
we need for investigating spatial
genomics data
we combine all of that in the easy to
use fully automated platform
and this platform allows researchers to
gain new insights into complex
biological systems again merscope is the
only proprietary platform for Murphy's
technology it includes not just the pla
not just the instrument itself but also
reagents Control software and analysis
software software to provide an
end-to-end solution with an exceptional
range of application interests and
industries
all of these tools come together to
offer a end-to-end system that makes
studying spatial biology easy for users
and so if we take a look at what that
data starts to look like this is an
example data set of mouse brain here
we're showing eight RNA subsets so we've
we've highlighted eight genes and looked
at the transcripts from all eight of
these genes
and what you can start to see across the
tissue section is different regions of
the tissue lighting up with different
RNA
transcripts and so what this allows you
to do is look at these areas of of the
tissue look at how they're interacting
what cells potentially are in those
areas and then in addition to this we
can zoom in and in this bubble we show a
200 by 200 Micron zoom in and you can
see that individual cells here are lit
up with different genes
and you can start to see how they
interact uh which genes look different
across different cells and really get an
get insight valuable insight into what
is going on on not just a tissue level
but on a cellular level and potentially
subcellular level as well
what a big Focus for us here at vizgen
is to continue to expand murscope
applications we we're we know that the
mersco platform offers the ability to
detect transcripts from 500 genes it
offers that subcellular resolution but
we want to continue to push forward in
developing product development and
enhancements for the murscope device
the first one a major Focus area for us
was in expanding the analytes detected
we want to move towards a multi-omic
measurement that includes different
types of analytes as we know that
transcripts alone don't tell you all of
the information on how a cell is
behaving and so that moved us towards
developing the merscope protein
co-detection solution
the second major area we wanted to move
into was enabling diverse a diverse
range of samples and unlocking those
archival samples especially ffpe tissue
samples we know that ffpe is a very
common tissue preservation technique and
so that moved us towards developing the
murscope ffpe solution
so now in these next few slides I'll go
through the mersco protein code
detection solution followed by
applications and then jump into the
merscope ffpe solution
okay so if we take a look at where we
were with uh the microscope device
about a month ago we had the ability to
look at just transcripts alone all right
and unfortunately we know that cellular
transcriptomes provide an impartial
picture they don't capture what's going
on on a protein level
and as a result the cellular State and
function cannot be fully captured by a
transcription profile alone
additionally we know that
post-translational modification
Downstream of transcription of certain
genes is important and has been
implicated in certain disease States
on top of that we know that
protein-based cell labeling it's common
within certain Fields especially
oncology and here at Vision what we want
to do is enable researchers to build
upon existing information build upon
existing techniques
and so at that time we only had the
ability to detect RNA alone
so through product development we wanted
to get to a point where we could provide
researchers stability to generate
multi-oma
data detect both RNA and protein at a
subcellular level
through our product development we we
accomplished this through oligo
conjugated secondary antibody speed uh
anti-species antibodies
how this works on a technical level we
have protein Target outlined in Gray
here and this can be a Target that a
researcher is interested in and they
have a primary antibody most researchers
will have a primary antibody they've
been using and the beauty of this system
is that it employs that primary antibody
provided by a researcher so you don't
need to go back to square one and
revalidate binding of a new antibody
and so in this example we have a protein
Target that that is being targeted by a
primary antibody from a host species for
instance we'll say a mouse
here we would use our anti-mouse oligo
conjugated secondary antibody this
antibody will bind to the primary
antibody and what it has is an oligo
conjugated to the back end of it this
oligo contains uh an encoding probe with
a detection probe binding site
when we get to the the round of
detection the complementary sequence on
that detection probe will bind to that
detection probe binding site
on the back end of the oligo
and the the fluorophore which is
attached to the detection probe will
then show signal that is proportional to
the presence of the protein
how we've packaged this is we offer
protein stain kits so those antibodies
are contained within these protein
stained kits we offer six different
types so an anti-mouse an anti-rabbit
anti-goat rat cumin and chicken
each one of these protein stain kits is
good for 20 samples 20 merscope samples
or verification samples which I'll get
into in a second it also contains the
blocking buffer that is required in
order to move through the workflow gear
now important for us here at vision is
we want to offer researchers the ability
to not just do the initial experiment
but do a verification so that they can
verify and optimize their sample prep
process before actually going into a
full protein code detection experiment
we have a similar setup with our sample
verification kits that'll allow
researchers to do an initial
verification
and so here what we also developed in
addition to the protein stain kits is
protein stain verification kits
these kits contain the reagents to
require
required to run through the protein
stain verification which is a shorter
overall protocol that allows users to
first test that the primary antibody
they're going to be using can be used in
conjunction with our protein stain kits
these protein stain verification kits
come in pack sizes of five we have two
of these so we have a mouse rabbit and
goat protein stain verification kit and
a rat human chicken verification kit
you can do one verification that you can
do verification of one antibody or two
or three they just have to be within
this grouping
so in a similar sense here we're giving
researchers a way to First verify before
moving into a full experiment which is
important
additionally as part of this solution we
also introduced a couple workflows so we
have a protein stain verification
workflow again this is where we're going
to verify that the antibodies we're
going to be used are going to work
and then we have a workflow for the full
murphish protein code detection
now what I have on the screen here is
what materials are required in order to
move through those protocols
and so in the Blue Table we have the the
materials that are required for the
protein verification workflow
so here the researcher would be
responsible for providing the primary
antibody or antibodies
you would need your microscope slide box
which contains those slides where you
can mount the tissue that you're going
to do the testing on
the murscope sample prep kit which
contains all of the buffers reagents
needed to process that sample to open up
the analytes for detection
along with the secondary or the protein
stain kits again these contain the
secondary oligo conjugated antibodies we
would use to detect those primary
antibodies
additionally here since we're not doing
a full merfish run you would need the
protein stain verification kit
so we have two variations of this
protocol depending on the antibodies
you're going to be running
if we look at the pink table we can see
the required materials for protein
staining within Murphy so this is true
protein code detection with with merfish
detection as well so we're going to
detect transcripts and proteins together
here you would need your primary
antibodies your murscope slide box again
your prep kit
you can Plex up to six antibodies per
experiment
just need to have different host specie
primary antibodies
this is where you would use your Gene
panel because now we are running foamer
fish your Gene Imaging kit that matches
that panel size and your cell boundary
staining kit this is an optional item of
course the only caveat here is if you
use a cell boundary staining kit you
cannot use it with the anti rabbit
protein stain kit
future development on this product will
hopefully eliminate this this
compatibility issue
the other great thing about this product
is that it is a very simple workflow
um and so if we look first at our
protein stain verification protocol
we're going to verify that the protein
stain is working properly
those of you familiar with are standard
sample prep protocol
this will look very familiar so we have
a sectioning fixing and perming that's
getting the sample ready for uh
detection of the analytes in this case
it's protein staining
for the actual protein staining itself
this is a high level overview of it very
simple it consists of multiple washes
with a blocking and incubation step a
primary antibody stain and incubation
step and a secondary antibody stain an
incubation step there
overall very simple protocol you do
those incubations you do the washes and
then following this you move back into
our standard sample prep protocol of gel
embedding tissue clearing which are
important for us and something that we
feel very confident that provides a a
way to clear the tissue and get the most
accurate data possible
we would then go into readout probe
hybridization pre-imaging staining and
imaging from here
following this we would look at the the
images
generated within our merge scope
visualizer system
from here if the if the sample is over
saturated we would potentially lower the
power settings within the Control
software these are power settings that
are easy to access while you set up your
experiment or you could also adjust the
primary stain concentration right so in
this way it's protein State verification
protocol allows us to optimize things
before we move into full protein code
detection
once we've done that we move into the
protein code detection protocol here
very similar again we have sectioning
fixing perming and then we go into cell
boundary staining and protein staining
it was important here that we provide
the ability to do one or the other or
both
the beauty of this system is that if you
are going to do both you do not have to
do double the time what you're going to
do is actually make a cocktail of
reagents
um and again both of these this entire
step here is completely optional so if
you're going to do cell boundary
staining you're going to follow the same
blocking primary antibody stain
secondary antibody stain similar if
you're doing only protein staining right
different blocking buffer that comes
with the protein stain that would be the
difference here then go through your
primary antibody stain and secondary
antibody stain the similar setup to our
protein verification kit
if you want to do both you're just going
to combine both reagents into a single
cocktail that is then going to be
incubated on the sample
um and so again very simple protocol it
provides flexibility and allows you to
generate that multinomic data
from this step you move through our
standard Murphy's probe hybridization
step that's where you would incubate
with your Gene panel
gel embedding and tissue clearing again
in order to clear the tissue and
generate that high accurate data
detection of those floors and then a
pre-treatment with that being poly T and
imaging
so now that I've kind of gone over how
the product works and the general
concept behind it I did want to show
some data and some applications on how
you could leverage some of this protein
code detection data
and so the first example here we have
u2os cell culture samples and here we
wanted to show how you can use and
Leverage The Protein code detection to
look at
interrogate subcellular functions right
so
here we've we've run a gene panel with
130 genes we detect transcripts from
those 130 genes together with a five
Plex protein stain
and if we start to look at that high
magnification in the top right image you
can see how we can use our visualizer
system to look at the protein staining
together with the transcript stain
taking that those High magnification
images and looking at within those cells
we can start to understand how
transcripts are interacting and where
they're potentially spatially
organized here
for instance fiberlin 2 we look at the
the transcripts which are shown in white
we look at lamp one grasp 2. actin and
hsp60 we can see that it is co-localized
with all of those protein markers
it is not collocalized with sox9
what this what this pushes us to
infer from this is that this fiberlin 2
transcript is co-localized with
cytoplasmic protein markers and
implicated potentially in cytoplasmic
regulation
a lot one on the other hand if we look
at this is very different than fiberlin
2. a lot one does not co-localize with
those cytoplasmic markers but does
co-localize with sox9
sox9 is a nuclear marker and so we can
infer from this that's a lot one is
potentially regulating nuclear signal
in addition to U2 OS we wanted to look
at a uh a potentially clinical sample so
fresh frozen human colon cancer
and here what we want to demonstrate is
the power of the protein co-detection to
further anotype cell types
with this panel we detected this panel
of 244 genes we detected over 35 000
total transcripts additionally we looked
at five protein stains
these protein stains were mostly geared
towards
proliferation markers and cancer markers
and so when we look at that we see pan
CK her2 Ki 67 and Vim are all those
cancer marker and proliferation markers
we see our standard expected spatial
patterning here
what we can further do from here is take
a look at is use these protein markers
to further annotype these cell types and
so we can use transcript data from that
we can do cell clustering analysis and
generate these cell clusters based on
which genes cells are expressing
we then can take those cells and
annotype them based on their spatial
clustering right where they're spatially
located
from there if we pull in the protein
staining we can then say these specific
cell types are located within this area
and using the protein markers for those
specific cell types further subtype some
of these cells so look at where
fibroblasts are and now they're a
population of fibroblasts that are
potentially located in a different area
and expressing a different subset of
genes right and so we can do this not
just for the immune cells but for the
cancer cells as well and what this gives
us is the ability to further annotype
these cells using the protein staining
and so the next major product I wanted
to focus on is our merscope formalin
fixed paraffin embedded solution
so if we look at tissue preservation
today there's a couple different major
types of preserving tissue
for DNA and RNA and sequencing analysis
fresh or fixed Frozen sample
preservation is preferred
these samples are usually stored at
minus 80. they're often not available
for clinical practices but they are they
do present compatibility with with
single cell sequencing analysis
however we know that ffpe samples formal
and fixed paraffin embedded samples
are the most widely used clinical sample
type
especially within oncology this is a
very common sample sample preservation
system as these samples can be stored at
room temperature they're also very good
at preserving tissue morphology
problem here is that it cross-links the
tissue it degrades it it can oftentimes
fragment RNA transcripts so even though
we have a great deal of archival sample
stored as this it presents a problem in
trying to analyze this and get at that
RNA within the tissue
so in order for us to open this tissue
up for spatial analysis we developed the
murscope ffpe product solution and this
solution is composed of three major
um
uh pieces components the first is
reagents so we have new kits that
provide reagents necessary to enable our
new ffpe sample prep protocol
this includes our sample prep kit our FF
our ffpe sample prep kit and our ffpe
slide box
the second major piece of this is our
new protocol and this is going to allow
us to unlock those ffpe samples open
them up
expose those analytes not just
transcripts but proteins as well uh and
Analysis and open those samples up for
Downstream Murphy analysis
the final major component is software
and so with this product release we will
be offering a new cell segmentation
offering which is based on Cell pose
which provides an improved cell
segmentation analysis for tissue samples
I'll kind of go through each one of
these
so the first major component as I
mentioned was our ffpe specific murscope
reagents so here we are releasing an
ffpe sample prep kit this is going to
contain those new reagents needed to
unlock those ffpe tissue samples
together with that new sample prep kit
we are also going to be offering a new
ffpe slide box this is going to contain
new slides new ffpe specific mer scope
slides that are going to be compatible
with our ffpe sample prep kit
if we start to look at how the portfolio
looks on the side here within this table
we now have different uh different
reagents for different sample types
right so for your fresh frozen and fixed
Frozen and sell culture samples you will
use our standard sample prep kit there
are two flavors of our slide boxes for
these our cell culture system requires
non-beaded slides in order for
researchers to grow the cell culture on
the actual slide itself
from here you use our standard cell
boundary staining kits are protein stain
kits uh our Gene panel and our Gene
Imaging kit
now with ffpe we've offered another
route for these samples you will use our
ffp slide box our ffpe sample prep kit
along with those common reagents again I
want to stress that our new protein
stain kits which I just went over they
are compatible with our ffpe sample prep
processing so very important uh very
powerful but now we have offered all of
these these different reagents that
researchers can use based on the sample
they want to investigate
so now the the second major component of
our ffpe sample prep solution is our
ffpe protocol
so here we had to kind of change things
up because we know ffpe samples they
have that wax they have that uh cross
length
um uh they they cross link the tissue so
we needed to
um develop a new a new protocol in order
to open the tissue up expose those
analytes for Downstream or fish Imaging
so moving through this protocol the
first piece is sectioning so we're going
to section A a slice off of an ffpe
block we would then Mount that on our
murscope slide
from here we would move into
deperifinization so chemical temperature
process to remove the wax from the
tissue
we then do a decrease in D cross-linking
procedure to remove those formal and
cross links and further improve access
to the analytes
we follow this with an anchoring
pre-treatment which allows uh improves
the RNA binding to the gel
in the in the next few steps here we'll
have gel embedding but this is an
initial treatment to improve that
binding
here again I want to stress that we have
secondary staining this is where we can
use that protein staining within the
ffpe workflow to get and generate that
multi-ohmic data so here this is
completely optional it includes the cell
boundary staining and the protein
staining to Mark those secondary
analytes
following this step we move into RNA
anchoring this is a final treatment to
prep the RNA for anchoring to the gel
we then move into gel embedding and
clearing gel embedding and clearing are
critical components of our protocols we
think that they help in our detection
our sensitivity and our specificity
right so first we embed the gel we
anchor those RNA the RNA
transcripts to the actual gel itself and
then we clear and digest all of the
protein from the sample and that lowers
the background and gets us that really
high sensitive signals
are highly sensitive signals
from here we do a hybridization where we
use our Gene panels to
hybridize our encoding probes to those
RNA targets WE Post we do a post
hybridization wash to remove the
unbounded coating probes and then we go
through murphish Imaging which is going
to flow in those detection probes that
will bind to the encoding probes that
are present
an optional step here is our auxiliary
Imaging here we can do further detection
of say our cell boundary stain or our
protein stain this happens outside of
merfish Imaging but still provides
flexibility to potentially detect those
proteins or detect highly abundant genes
the final piece of our ffpe sample prep
solution is our cell segmentation
algorithm and so this is a new machine
learning driven cell pose cell
identification it provides unrivaled
processing of spatial genomics data
across tissue types
we're extremely excited about this it
improves certainly improved segmentation
within ffpe samples where you can have
these smaller cell types
it more accurately captures the cell
shape in these dense tissues
it is completely integrated into the
murscope user interface so users that
currently have a microscope right now
they will receive a software update that
will introduce this new cell
segmentation algorithm as an option
right so we won't replace Watershed
segmentation that's currently available
this will be an additional option
provide more flexibility for researchers
not just for ffpe samples although we
think this is going to vary this is
going to be very useful within ffp
segmentation but they can start to use
this segmentation across fresh frozen
fixed Frozen samples as well
and so now just going through
applications of our ffpe sample prep
protocol here
uh one of the the first major uh area we
wanted to focus on within ffp is in the
quality of the data we're generating
right so
um here at Vision we are very much
focused on developing high quality
spatial genomics data
if we take a look up top here we're
using our ffpe Mouse brain sample and
what we've done is we've compared our
merfish counts within that ffpe sample
to bulk RNA sequencing
what we get is a highly correlated data
0.88 r value
across the entire expression profile so
we're not having to insert a line that
breaks this data apart
between low expressing and medium
expressing or high expressing genes we
get this correlation across the entire
expression profile which is very
important because we know researchers
are going to be interested in not just
those high and medium abundant genes but
also low expressive genes as well
the second figure on the the top here we
look at replicates between ffpe Mouse
print samples extremely high correlation
indicating that we are getting that
reproducibility
the other place we really wanted to
Benchmark
um and generate a kind of a quality
measure of our ffp sample prep it's
benchmarking it against our fresh frozen
protocol and so you can see here that if
we look we take a sample that is ffp and
we take a fresh frozen sample and we
compare merfish from both of those
samples we get a very high correlation
of 0.95
we went further here to compare these an
annotyped annotated these cell types
here within ffp and fresh frozen samples
and then
spatially compared those those cell
types Within These two sample types and
so if we look we can see all cells
between the ffpe and fresh frozen sample
we then look at the spiny projection
neurons and you see a very similar
spatial orientation for those cells
oligodendrocytes and cortical excitatory
neurons
um so basically we are seeing the same
spatial distribution of these cell types
uh within ffpe and within fresh Frozen
cells
which is it's very important
uh we we didn't want to just focus
within brain uh tissue we wanted to
um push our ffpe system and apply this
into uh cancer types and additional
additional tissue types as well
uh what we see is high sensitivity and
special specificity across multiple ffpe
samples so you can see up here we have
human ovarian cancer lymph node tonsil
human lung cancer and skin and human
kidney
in addition to just showing that we can
successfully demonstrate our fish here
we took these six samples six additional
ffpe tissue types and look at the
correlation coefficient again looking at
the data we've generated using merfish
comparing it to bulk RNA sequencing we
see very high correlation coefficients
across all of these tissue types
um which is incredibly important and
again this is across the entire
expression profile
and then finally as I mentioned before
we want a a key uh feature of both of
these products is their ability to work
together so having the ability to do
that protein code detection within ffpe
samples and so we have a microscope ffp
uh We've demonstrated this within human
colon cancer ffpe sample here we did
staining protein code detection with six
proteins and so on the left you can see
pan CK SMA e-cad herein these are lit up
within our visualizer these are the
protein targets and on the right the
distribution of all of our transcripts
we've detected we detected over 67
million transcript counts so credible
data
we look in you know zooming into these
areas we can see where these proteins
are different you are are expressed
differently
additionally looking at transcripts we
can see how they are expressed
differently as well but again the idea
here is that we can successfully
generate protein code detection data
within our uh within ffpe samples using
our protocol
and so just uh very quickly conclusion
here you know with the mer scope uh we
see a lot of advantages right we want to
continue to push the boundaries of
spatial transcriptomics not just with
the platform itself but with new
application areas new products uh that
do that so you know we have that high
cell throughput from a flexibility
standpoint we've we've only improved
this by providing a solution for uh ffpe
samples
we've also from a multiplexing
standpoint we have that ability to cover
hundreds of thousands of genes using
custom Gene panels that you can develop
but now we are moving that multiplexing
into multi illness right it's not just
transcripts anymore it's protein data as
well
we combine that with our resolution
and our sensitivity and specificity
allows researchers to generate spatial
genomics data and now multi-ohmic data
across a wide range of samples and
answer those tough complex biological
questions
so I'd be happy to take any questions at
this point